Neuropathy is getting worse over the last three months. I've had lots of symptoms. I used
the rebuilder and it's not working for me very much. What else can I do? So I think I
address that on this question of the things that you want to do with the
apathy. You have to do a lot of things with the apathy. You got to understand that
your nerves grow back very slowly. So you have to give your three months is not
enough time to even assess whether you know anything you're doing is working
so and you please do watch the video on our store. Go to our store and if you
didn't get the rebuilder from us, go to the store, look up Rebuilder and watch
the video that I created. I actually created it for practitioners and the
apathy to your pathways and what I actually take you place.